[Music]
ah goby I'm just trying to look at your
insides okay let me try it I don't know
what I'm doing I can direct you yeah
he's getting mad I think you can see him
looking at you like um he don't like
that probe
so today's not off to a great start
we're trying to Ultrasound our camel
goby and he's not having any of it
okay all right we're done nope he ain't
gonna like it go be like growl farts at
me at the same time I mean I guess he's
a multitasker
I'd probably be more afraid of his fart
that Woody's bite but luckily the wind's
going that way
yeah
[Music]
today is a very busy day have fun with
your gazelle the hospital schedule is
absolutely packed and I'm bouncing
around all over the zoo checking on
cases right now I'm headed down to the
koala building to check on ruolum she
has an also of her right eye which is
resolving but now she has intermittent
bulging of that eye which is an unusual
sign but could be an indication of
something more Sinister Taylor hi
come on up hi welcome where is the old
Beast open our favorites oh my gosh
en is our geriatric female koala
um she's definitely an old girl that has
medical issues from arthritis in
different joints clearly this ulcer
thing going on and um she is special
she's definitely one of the first koalas
I've ever worked with and when she's
feeling well she definitely gives us a
run for our money
how is she doing she's doing great I
think her eye looks a lot better
obviously you'll be the judge of that we
noticed that everyone's eye was looking
a little unusual a couple of weeks ago
and had the vets take a look at it then
and that's when we discovered that she
had an ulcer at first we tried eye drops
with through Wallen but it was a little
difficult because koalas don't really
have a tendency to look up they tend to
look down and trying to get an eye drop
in an animal as their head is pointed
down can be very difficult really
challenging
her eyes been open more good I don't
think that content lens isn't I think
I'm gonna use her ladder okay eventually
we had a specialist come in and she
recommended that we try contact lens to
kind of try to help the healing how big
was that contact was it like a normal
soft contact
what are the hard contact no it was like
a squishy soft one well it might be
still on here hi sweet girl
we used a dog contact lens in rwanda's
eye because they simply don't make
content lenses that are shaped to a
koala's eye so we use the next best
thing just as a let's see if it works
kind of thing her eyes been more open
today than she's been having it normally
that also looks fantastic I can
understand how a contact lens for Ru
Allen that doesn't fit specifically to
her eye would be very uncomfortable I
personally find contact lenses a little
bit irritating just because they can be
very itchy they can fall out really
easily unless you have a really good fit
which is one of the reasons I hate
wearing contact lenses and always wear
my glasses well thank you brew the good
thing is is it does seem to have helped
for the short time that they were in
place like if I sit in the middle yeah
they can't quite touch me looking at it
now it's night and day from Saturday
when we last saw it and debrided the
surface of it so I think it's going to
be absolutely fine without any problems
but I worried about the bulging of her
right eye so I'm going to get her on the
animal health schedule unfortunately my
schedule is pretty packed so Randy's
going to be taking care of row Allen and
I know she's in really good hands
I'm really encouraged that Priya thinks
the eye is healing really well we'll see
what Dr Randy thinks when he sees her in
the meantime we're just going to keep a
close eye on her eyes
[Music]
today I want Shannon to come down and
assess Bob I just have some concerns I
want to share with her so the best way
to kind of look at the monkeys is when
they're using their yard and to let them
use our yard and really get the full
range of motion with these guys we offer
them lots of fun in Richmond I'm gonna
head into the vervet kitchen I'm
bringing a couple of fun toys for the
vervets right now for their enrichment
we're giving some coolers just because
the design of the habitat is actually
pretty friendly to giving them Oddball
things hey hey hey hey what's up because
they're so smart they can get into
almost anything I like to close them but
not too tight not too tight they'll
start eating holes through them if we go
too tight it's fun to try to find
different ways to keep them mentally
active Todd likes to eat on top so oh I
always put a little bit in the cup
holders okay okay cool I'll set these
here
they're so cute so since it's nice and
hot
give them some yummy
cold treats
in typical vervet fashion they're
extremely curious and they want to check
out everything and at least see what it
has to offer and usually those old dirty
shoes offer yummy treats all right all
set yep okay purpose of enrichment is
you want to give them activities that
can kind of last and keep them occupied
and keep them engaged the monkeys are
probably some of the hardest to enrich
though because they're pretty smart so
they figured this out pretty quickly
here come on come on sassy good job
Lucy
come on lose
good girl
we have five rabbit monkeys in our
troops we have two males Bob and Todd
and three females Betsy Lucy and Sassy
they are so cute they're tiny they're
fluffy they're so smart and they have so
much personality did you find something
in there
if you're looking at pictures African
campsites and you see a mischievous
monkey that is most likely a vervet
monkey
hey Bob so Bob is the protector of the
group he's protecting everybody right
now
Bob is the sweetest monkey but over the
past week week and a half two weeks he's
really kind of starting to isolate
himself he's acting like he doesn't feel
well he's just acting off so I'm cursing
and stuff so yeah yeah we've seen him
coughing on and off I think that's
becoming more prevalent okay I'm hopeful
that it's allergies because that just
means it's nothing
um I am a little bit fearful though that
he might have an infection possibly an
upper respiratory infection because of
the coughing and because he's acting a
little bit down he hasn't had the CT we
were talking about the CTE
but it would be really nice to see his
lungs just to make sure it's not
anything more that's making him cough
yep sure okay he's just not himself okay
it's good that you know him so well so I
love that fluffy man
he really is cute he's like a giant
teddy bear right big teddy bear so cute
all of our verbits are special but Bob
is especially cuddly and just sweet so
you know we definitely don't want
anything to be wrong with him
so okay well we'll talk to Animal Health
and see what they want to do and we'll
get something on the calendar and go
from there sound good yes okay I feel
better I feel better good good good
awesome all right thanks enjoy
I'm really excited today I'm actually
going to be headed down to the Wilds to
help with a really cool Rhino procedure
new baboons will be here I will
definitely not have turned out it's
always super fun working with the Wilds
team I spent three years there so going
back and working with the same crew kind
of feels like home
hi you oh when I came down the barn I
got a big surprise Dr Priya showed up
from the zoo it's been a long time since
I seen her I was actually her intern
back when I first started here about 10
years ago so we go way back and so it's
great seeing her Pria is an awesome
person so being able to work with her on
this procedure just makes everything so
much fun it's always nice to have a
quick chat catch up with everyone but to
also work with the southern white rhino
ball is pretty phenomenal I just hope we
find something in his mouth yeah
kingelli has been having some dental
issues over the past few months so he's
being anesthetized today to have a
really good oral exam my responsibility
today is to kind of help with the
anesthesia part of it to make sure that
Priscilla has hands if she needs help
intubating the animal but to also read
out some of the blood values in the
blood gas results we're getting
throughout the procedure I just want to
make sure everybody knows Dr louder a
Veterinary Dentist in the scrubs over
there we're going to do anesthesia so
that we can then do dental exam this
Rhino's birth name is kingelli but here
at the Wilds we like to give stuff
nicknames and of course the easiest
nickname for this guy is Kenny G Kenny G
is my man he came in here and he was
very nervous about aggressive behavior
because of that nervousness so I spent a
lot of time sitting there for hours and
hours feeding him petting him getting
him used to human contact and now he's a
pretty well-rounded in animals
traditionally we give them all a pile
grain and their hay if we give him a
traditional pile of grain usually about
half the time he starts choking on it
obviously something's going on with his
mouth and he was knocking all the food
he needs so getting this looked at now
is very important happy rhinos are
healthy rhinos oh hey sleepy boy
you're okay good boy immobilizing animal
is large comes with a large amount of
risk funky yellow move up
good job hey buddy easy you need to act
fast in order to try and help him get
into the position we need
we're gonna slip a rope over his horn
and kind of guide him in the correct
position I'm trying to take him that way
that way just because he's so big if he
goes down where we can't work with him
there's almost nothing we can do except
end the procedure and wake him up
I just pull the Rope around me and I use
all my body weight to pull him in the
direction we need him to go he's a big
boy if he pulls I'm in big trouble
that's pretty rigid no he's gonna he's
gonna go he's going squeeze watch the
Rope squeeze squeeze
[Music]
four thousand pound animal and the
anesthetic has not yet taken effect if
kinkeli decides to put up a fight Cody
could get seriously injured it looks
pretty rigid it's awesome no he's gonna
he's dropping the animal management team
are really focusing on making sure he's
in an appropriate position so that we
have really good access to his mouth oh
he's going squeaks watch the real
squeeze squeeze
the best you can you got it wow all
right good job we are able to manipulate
kg into the correct position for the
procedure still breathing nice
well to get Dr louder in there and start
this dental procedure okay you can relax
his head all right slow and Jack
one of the tools that was used was a
little Jack it looks like kind of a mini
car jack that was used to wedge in
between his Jewel and open up his mouth
I got the soft palate awesome just
trying to get the glottis down all right
tubes in position can someone Push It
Forward because I can't do it with where
I am all right let's try and give a
breath and see where we're at
all right take a break thank you
sometimes when animals are under
anesthesia there are some involuntary
muscle spasm and Kenny G's lip is
quivering a little bit right now we're
pretty sure that's just something not to
be worried about it's just an
involuntary muscle thing their mouth is
so specialized for grazing that it's
hard to see the inside of it their
head's always pointing down and it's
like a big tube it's very long and it's
very deep so you can't really see all
the way back there so being able to get
a good look inside the mouth of a white
rhino is pretty unique
food impaction has got some periodontal
Pockets I've got some nastiness in there
yeah he's just got some points Dr louder
has found points it's a term that we use
in horses and really rhinoceroses are
really closely related to horses and it
means that there are sharp literally
points on the edges of their molar teeth
yeah we'll take care of that and that
smoothies points out other than that he
looks pretty good okay it's really about
the best possible thing we could find
all we need to do is go in there and
grind down those points and kingelli be
a lot more comfortable how are you guys
good with this one's right
all right this part's done thank you so
we're going to go ahead and reverse from
asinel Naltrexone he's moving his back
body camazole out
he hurts you see I told you right it's
amazing working with the vet team great
teamwork great team atmosphere and
everyone kept the cool throughout and it
was great to see Cody shine Cody was a
young intern when I was still at the
wild so it's amazing to see him in this
position of leadership and knowledge so
that was phenomenal kg is starting to
wake up it's a big sigh relief for me
there we go
good boy I'm very happy for how this
procedure went I'm glad it all went well
good team effort
knowing what the underlying issue was
with kng's eating problems is great now
we know what to look for in the future
and how to make sure it is a long and
happy life that's very important to me
I'm very excited that we figured this
out for him
so I'm going to get Ben's meat and mouse
ready before he gets trained so this
morning I'm going to do some training
with Ben so he's ready for his upcoming
exam to check to see how he's doing with
his diabetes so we start out with that
because those are two of his favorites
and then I'm getting some of his treats
together
Ben is our male been to wrong he's been
at our Zoo now for five six years
been wrongs are a medium-sized mammal
from Southeast Asia they're commonly
called Bearcat they're not a bear or a
cat
hey bud
are you ready for your procedure Ben's
very timid if you do anything that
Spooks him sometimes it takes a couple
days to get him to come back up to you
that becomes difficult for us because we
can't handle him and if he's not feeling
well and we can't get him to come over
then we can't give him his injections so
we do work with him every day so he is a
little on the spoiled side gets a lot of
extra little treats and does a little
begging but you know that's okay
we're good it has taken quite a while to
get him to trust
but he's really doing great
this morning he trained very well every
time I asked him to hold he stayed there
he allowed me to pinch and touch him so
he is ready for his hand injection on
exam day
[Music]
thank you
Australia we're headed down for Ruan
we're taking rule into Animal Health
today for a full exam under anesthesia
Dr Priya successfully treated the ulcer
on her eye but she's still a little
concerned about the bulging of ruellen's
eye she wasn't able to fit us into our
schedule so Dr Randy's going to take
over and do the exam under Wallen today
go see Dr Young today I know
so going into any exam where there's
going to be anesthesia it's very
stressful it's very nerve-wracking for
me I have all those emotions and I have
all those feelings
hi beautiful
I have worked with Roland for many many
years everyone's had two Joeys here so
I've gotten to see her you know grow and
to become a mom and to take on that role
there's definitely a strong connection
with Ru Allen hi you ready to go to
hospital she looks ready all right
that was easy
there's definitely an inherent risk with
koalas and anesthesia but after a while
just kind of becomes clear that you need
to know what you're up against if you're
going to be able to do anything about it
she's a fighter sometimes that's why I
want you to get her I know you're the
professional you turn them I'll step out
after every wall in his hand I have to
step out of the room I'm actually
pregnant and there's a lot of stuff
that's involved with the medical
procedure that I can't actively partake
in there's a slight chance that the
anesthetic gas could have an effect on a
pregnancy mostly we don't know we don't
want to take any chances so I have to
watch from the hallway through the
window but everyone that's in there I
trust explicitly it's really difficult
to watch from outside but it's the
safest thing for me and I know that
Ramon's in good hands
[Music]
thank you
I could hear the grunting that everyone
was making pretty much through the door
she was not happy as to be expected
Harry crabby koala she may have peed on
your shoe
that's okay everyone was completely
resigned and fined with this whole
procedure that's not her wallet at all
and so I'd rather see her true self and
her true colors and know that she's a
little bit of post what we're doing and
she's going to let us know she doesn't
hold back
okay
I'm gonna go back and look at her skull
that'll do
for an old koala I'd say she's doing
pretty well but look at these x-rays
compared to two years ago and see if
much has changed but there's nothing
dramatic that jumps out with the x-rays
of the skull I don't see anything
obvious but skull x-rays are difficult
to interpret that's where CT comes in so
we'll take her next into CT and get
those really good three-dimensional
images that will help us decide whether
there's anything abnormal there ready
for CT
I'm really nervous for the whole
procedure I'm a little anxious about
what it'll show until we're a couple
days even away from the procedure I
think I'll still be pretty nervous about
this whole thing
okay
everyone out
this is one of Taylor's favorite animals
she's worked with real woman for years
and again real well it's sort of a
golden girl and has some special needs
so we're hoping for a completely normal
CT exam my biggest concern especially
for a geriatric animal is that there
could be a tumor growing in the area
behind your eye if that's the case
there's probably nothing we can do for
her
all done do you want to check it Randy
yeah freewellin's had some issues with
her eyes in the last couple months once
she had some issue with the actual eye
itself and then an issue with the eye
bulging So today we're doing the full
workup on rouon the worst case scenario
is that this is a tumor tumors in that
area spread readily and that's a very
difficult area to work in so there's
always a level of concern especially
with geriatric animals okay she's good
good when I first look at the CT I'm
pleased the bone looks normal the soft
tissue looks normal eye looks normal
there's no abnormal structures there's
really good news I didn't look at her
last x-rays in comparison but today's
don't look bad nothing prominent on the
CTN no I don't see anything on her face
I did a quick scan of the CT and
everything's symmetrical okay so she's
lost a lot of muscle mass which is
typical for older animals of any type
people as well and I think what we're
having now is that she loses muscle mass
on the side of her face her eye is more
prominent but it's not really bigger so
instead of the eye getting bigger the
muscle mass is getting smaller and the
eye just appears more prominent and we
had contrast which would show us
anything okay
I couldn't see anything that was going
on I just saw everybody looking very
intently so I wasn't sure if they had
found something so when he came out and
seemed relieved and seemed relaxed I
literally had a huge sigh of relief
anytime we do a procedure on a geriatric
animal especially one who's lived much
of its life with us that has good close
friends who are very concerned about her
it's always a little stressful an older
animal with sort of vague signs you
never know what you're going to find and
there's always a sense of relief when
our initial assessment says everything
looks like it's working well this is
just an age-related change it gets
everybody a huge sigh of relief
we can get the Bear Hugger on her when
she's in her crate all good for me to be
in yes it's all okay well thank you we
just turned it off
comments
hi there hi we need those gloves that's
Indiana here everyone did absolutely
fantastic she looks great she's holding
on she's gripping she's doing everything
she should she looks fantastic she's
like what is this
everyone will be around for many many
years she'll be able to see my baby grow
up a little bit as well and I can't wait
for the baby to meet her someday you
ready
oh she's moved around the other side of
her tree she must be ready
[Music]
here
just looking at fun stuff seeing fun
things
what do you think you want to play fetch
[Music]
and then what do we do
can we come back
he's a smart bird Ronaldo is our black
vulture he's an ambassador with us in
animal programs no one ever talks about
getting regular exercise for your
rehabilitated vultures ha it's cool to
get them out and get him exercise like
this because he's not able to fly
because of his improperly fused the
other Wings you can see his left wing
kind of droops out to the side yeah
thank you for showing it off that was
very very considerate of you he is Goofy
he's smart he's outgoing likes long
walks on the beach probably a scent of
lavender anything from Cinnabon he's
great I love him he's absolutely the
light of my life oh we stretching we
love the weather we're handsome chicken
most of the birds that I'm lucky to work
with because I love nicknames I will
call them some different form of chicken
chicken of death and being a vulture I
call Ronaldo chicken of Death Or Death
chicken big nasty death chicken nasty in
this connotation is a good so gotcha
Richard how tall how tall are you
oh he's a tall boy vultures are really
misunderstood they are really underrated
they are so important to every ecosystem
on Earth just about and the fact that
they get a bad rap just you know kind of
rubs me the wrong way so the fact that
I'm able to have a close relationship
with such an awesome animal and then
also get to show him off to people and
let them see how cool vultures are it's
just the greatest feeling in the world
all right we're starting to fill up you
want to go home
good boy
you got it chicken
ready the city now we're coming Sunday
I learned to drive really slow because
my parents are in town and my mom hates
how I drive so I drove like my
grandparents around the car very safe I
will have you now
today we're going to anesthetize Ben Ben
is one of our adult male binturongs and
he's had diabetes for about the last two
years the keepers have done an amazing
job at monitoring it and treating it but
it's been about a year since we've had a
Hands-On exam with him and evaluated him
completely with x-rays and ultrasounds
Ben and I have a strange relationship in
the sense that when he sees me he
definitely shows some degree of anxiety
and so I try and stay out of his visual
bubble as much as I can and I kind of
let Cindy take over same volume as
before
0.7 this involves giving him an
injection that Cindy has been training
for for years it's part of her insulin
injection so he will come into a shoot
Cindy will do the injection
good hold we inject him every day with
insulin but the needle is a lot bigger
when you give the medication for
immobilization he sees it he knows right
away that oh no this is something
different and so he's not quite as
Welling
I got it all I was able to inject but I
was not able to get all the injection in
he needs more he keeps open his eyes at
us so
okay I'm gonna draw some stuff up do you
want to do it or do you want me to do it
I'll let you do it okay Cindy injected
him and she did come out and say I don't
think he got everything so I kind of
knew that he probably wasn't going to be
completely asleep okay buddy let me
think I'm thinking okay do you want to
go in a crate I'm going to try to put
him in a crate
quiet and dark and wonderful he went in
the crate good boy
and then he came right back out
I saw that but I thought you had a plan
to be honest
it's just
it's a mess
[Music]
I guess it's not going well he's hissing
and spitting and being wild back so I
can't put my arm in there so we're gonna
have him run up the log I'm gonna try
and inject him as he's lighting up the
log okay we'll see what happens
otherwise we either postpone the dark
good luck
foreign
we were trying to make sure he was in a
safe location for both of us
I was able to poke him in the bottom
with his induction agents and he went up
on the shelf and went to sleep which he
could have done right from the beginning
very relieving
it was a it was a huge relief to get the
injection then Noah likes sharks and I
can't say I blame him once he's asleep
we will take him up to the hospital and
begin our complete exam
got it all right ready George
well that was quite the adventure Ben is
a binturong or a bearcat with diabetes
and he's coming in for his annual exam
we got you here Ben
yeah today no escaping Benjamin it took
a little longer than expected to induce
Ben so we are behind schedule this isn't
great because we have a very packed
schedule at the hospital so we're gonna
have to be very focused and very
efficient to get back on track yeah not
to Dave Benjamin we want to make sure we
get all of his monitoring on
he's doing everything to make life
difficult to die all right Benjamin at
this point in time Ben is being treated
with diabetes as aggressively as we
possibly can if you want to just try and
get blood and that way we can see what
his glucose is while I'm doing this the
keepers are treating him like he would a
cat at home or humans they are giving
daily insulin injections and they are
testing his urine every single day for
glucose so some phenomenal care and
phenomenal teamwork on their part to
really provide Ben with the best care
and Welfare that we can she got chunky
Cindy but in the good way he's perfect
he's in the perfect way
I think Ben is extra special to me he is
one of the most rewarding animals that
I've worked with up to this point
because it has been such a challenge and
this has been a lot of work to get him
to this point Cindy you
to use why are you nervous nervous
it's like that it
I don't know no I'm not nervous so two
things I'm really worried about with Ben
are the blood glucose and his kidneys to
make sure there's no damage to kidneys
worst case scenario would be that his
numbers have not changed or they are
elevated and we not only have to inject
once but probably twice a day whole
Ben's being squeezed and prodded and
pushed he did not want to play
yeah that looks really nice well it's a
nice kidney
and some clump
so I remember him having a fairly thick
bladder wall it's much better than that
but see this it's still a little thicker
than normal his bladder wall was a
little bit thickened which makes me
think he may have some grumbling
underlying urinary issues but his liver
had normal structure it looked beautiful
on the screen his kidneys look great
sticking so urine done lots of urine and
we were able to get a very very large
urine sample which is definitely going
to help us evaluate things The Next Step
was to take X-rays ready
that looks great things look good Cindy
good yeah this heart even looks normal
so yay done with x-rays you just have to
deal with the guilt of doing it
he's not gonna forgive me he's not going
to forgive any of us for a while so we
took full body X-rays and everything
looked pretty good so hopefully fingers
crossed his urine samples come back
normal his blood samples don't show us
any other issues that might be going on
we got all the blood and the urine so
hopefully if everything comes back
normal that's our last exam for him for
a while today was stressful I'm sure
he's very happy it's over I know I am
okay thank you bye-bye
[Music]
is you ready to hook him on some
reindeer today I'm ready I like how one
of them's standing there with her feet
and the open the water bowl right now
it's like so you go get a manicure you
soak your cuticle first today we're
going to be doing hoof Trims on our
three reindeer girls sugar plum
Snowflake and Abby
so if we did not do hoof trims they're
supposed to get overgrown which can
affect the way they walk how pressure is
applied to their legs and down the lines
that could cause medical issues the
reason we're doing it they're Hooves
right now is because currently the girls
are shutting their velvet that's the
outer coating of the antler the furiness
of it we're kind of at that sweet spot
we have to worry about their antlers
getting nicked at the same time the
Velvet is still present so that provides
us a little safety as well so first up
is Abby Eddie set
Stephen got her she's good we kind of
have a process down of how we're going
to do this and this entire thing they'll
be awake for they ready to pull me in
there my name is Mel Jones I'm a farrier
also known as a horseshoe or trimmer how
much does she weigh
a little different but they're Hooves
hey that was done we're gonna rotate her
counterclockwise okay
okay I am between our antlers so with
the way we're having to restrain Abby
right now I'm actually ending up with my
head in between Abby's antlers so that
can be a little dangerous I have his
life between my hands because this is
practice for what for the next two yeah
yeah this is the easy one all right
she's done okay okay let's get Josh out
we just finished up Abby's hoof trim
peace out
now we're going to move to snowflake a
little nervous because she's more of
skittish reindeer okay
she wants
she wants yep
you're having to restrain an animal you
know it is a little nerve-wracking but
also my primary job is to make sure that
our reindeer are safe
okay that one's done
okay can you sneak out
you know what they call this reindeer
aerobics reindeer I love it our reindeer
girls are not small so having to Buddy
up and restrain them is definitely a
taxing process okay you ready okay all
right
okay
don't fix hook term up pretty well up
next we have sugar plum and as a
reindeer she's actually the most calm
and does the best by herself everyone
good yeah
no I'm good she's our largest female so
hoping she continues that calm demeanor
throughout the whole thing
you okay John
sugar I've lost her oh easy
[Music]
easy damn it
let her go let's let her go so today
we're working on doing hoof Trims on our
reindeer girls we've gotten two of them
done and now we're working on sugar and
she is giving us a little bit of trouble
is everyone all right
do you have all your teeth yeah I just
got the Velvet in my mouth
let's give her a minute sugar plum did
rear up and her antler kind of hit my
jaw thank you I have no hard feelings I
still love her just as much as all the
other girls so we just gotta hurry up
and finish this one hoof so we can get
her out of the barn I know baby I know
we're almost
nice work guys it is just a day at the
nail salon
come on cute creature see a shadow
hi Poe is a bush baby God you're cute
bush babies are one of the quickest
animals we work with look at her go
she's so quick
she's using those ears look at her go
checking it out
they're really great jumpers yeah
isn't that cute so depending on the
height of the tree they could jump up to
20 feet from tree to tree whoa no
problem holy cow we could try even a
little bit further if you want my
favorite thing to do with Poe is to just
interact with guests being able to show
people what they do naturally is our
whole goal because that's more memorable
than us just telling them them actually
getting to see it and getting to
experience it that's what we're trying
to accomplish you could do it Sis I have
broad shoulders I've been working out
whoa good job she did it come on up
sorry why why
um do you feel the sticky hand I feel
the sticky hands are she still urine
washing yeah is that why you're doing
this yeah oh you're so cute I can you're
in watch so they'll pee on their hands
and feet and then run across the trees
I'm very aware she's a hair stylist a
little added hair gel for you thank you
I needed that what we want to do touch
the heart to teach the Mind those
special moments that are very memorable
he will always remember those sticky
hands sticking onto his head
[Music]
it's a mess
I'm gonna have to go home and take a
shower now
[Music]
good morning are you ready for some
Monkey Business yes waiting on Heather
and then totally ready Shannon got a
hold of the Vets they agreed to come
down here and do a full workup on Bob
he's been isolating himself lately which
is not like him at all so we're gonna
sedate Bob in our shoot and then we're
going to take him up to the hospital we
can do a full workup he's just been
acting a little strange he's just been
acting not like Bob he's not very into
food which he normally is a lot we've
been seeing coughing we've been seeing
sneezing he doesn't smoke does he I hope
not who knows with these monkeys I get a
little concerned with the middle age to
older animal that's coughing that it
could be a variety of things one
obviously is a respiratory infection
like pneumonia but older animals so you
have to consider heart disease so I'm
waiting for Heather I want Heather to
poke him the last few times we've had to
sedate our monkeys I have been the one
to do the hand injection which I don't
mind doing but I don't always want to be
the bad guy so today I am going to make
Heather the bad guy hello everyone I'm
here here okay we've been waiting on you
you're the bad guy today we're all set
to go when you're ready all right all
right well I'll go give him a little
stabby stop thank you
managing the vervet monkeys is easy
because they're so well habituated the
keepers will be able to bring Bob into a
narrow Runway and hand inject him with
the anesthetic drug so it's very smooth
induction I don't have to Dart him I
have to chase him around yes you are
all right Bob Joe I'm always nervous
anytime we need to do a sedation with
any of our animals good job I love these
monkeys and so it'd be like a member of
your family going to the hospital for a
procedure
good job Heather was successful in her
hand injection of Bob he's sedated and
now we're going to head up to the
hospital to do his workup time for some
Monkey Business this is the hard side to
back into you're crushing in Avery
you're doing amazing I love this
cheering section I have oh my gosh the
amazing thing is her eyes are closed
when we get back to the hospital the
first step is to get our patients
stabilized so we'll put it in a tracheal
tube in to get him on gas anesthesia
we'll start an IV catheter to maintain
fluids before we start doing anything
diagnostic we want to make sure a
patient is stable resting comfortably in
a good plane of anesthesia he's got some
congestion on the left side okay which
may be from the anesthesia but it may be
part of the cough so we'll get a good
look on x-ray good it's not pregnant
that's good
what did he say he's not pregnant I'm
pregnant
Bob is definitely my favorite we just
call him a teddy bear because he's just
so sweet he loves to train he loves to
interact with us and he's just really a
big huggable lovable guy
come along Bob
let's take some X-rays
heart disease would be a serious
situation could be fatal so I'm hoping
that's not the case
you ready for chest
ready
done
all right looks all around doesn't it
looks a little round
her looks all around doesn't it
Bob is a nine-year-old male verbit
monkey who has had about a two-week
history of respiratory science so he's
copying some on and off not eating well
and just not really thriving the first
thing I notice on x-ray is his heart
looks a little rounded if this is a sign
of an enlarged heart it would suggest
that his problem is really into heart
disease
Eric can you grab the food pole yeah
yeah we'll move into CT and I like CT
Imaging for lots of reasons but it'll
give us a lot more detail we'll use a
contrast study which will highlight
areas in his chest we'll be able to see
his heart his lungs well and also his
abdominal organs too so we can see if
there's a mass or abnormalities in his
kidney or liver or anything else I am
nervous and a little bit scared that it
could be something more risky than an
upper respiratory infection I'm still
really hopeful that it's not I'm
definitely anxious to find out what's
going on so we're here when I look at
Bob's CT the first thing I notice is his
heart looks fine it's perfectly normal
but it's immediately apparent that he's
got some areas of abnormal lungs on both
sides okay so this is Bob's CT of his
lungs with contrast and then we get down
here look at that like what are all
those wormy things those are vessels oh
okay but that's wrong look how much
white there is there so what is that
it's pneumonia and then you get down
here there's more there that's a fair
amount of consolidation so that whole
lung tip is solid oh okay it's not great
news we don't want our animals to have
pneumonia but it's not the worst news
small isolated area he's doing well
otherwise he's not coughing up a bunch
of friends have a fever so I think we
caught a pneumonia very early in the
stage and it should clear up that's what
you wanted to hear right that's exactly
what I wanted to hear so part of my job
is to think about these animals all the
time I think about them when I'm here I
think about it when I'm at home
my God
um you know
I think about them all the time
[Music]
I'm gonna get past this sentence I swear
to God
when something's wrong with them I don't
feel okay so knowing that he's gonna be
okay is a huge relief to me
happy relieved
calm
I feel good today is really good these
are happy tears I'm super happy that
Bob's gonna be totally fine
sleepy monkeys
I think we can take him back and he can
wake up there amongst his friends the
best Teddy Bear around
[Music]
I'm on my way to meet Cindy at the bin
strong habitat and update her own van hi
good news yeah so Ben's results came
back and everything was great yes
because it's normal like his fructose me
in that blood test we look at to
indicate what his diabetes control has
been over the last few weeks looks great
job absolutely absolutely Ben's Really
Gonna Cruise so he's gonna get his daily
insulin injections he's living really
well here at the zoo he's having a great
life and the keepers are very closely
monitoring him so how's he doing now
we're working on getting him back in
there and building up the truck okay
the injections again so the good news is
that we at least know those doses work
right we don't have to change anything
so as soon as he's back to letting you
do the injections we know kind of what
works and what to get him back so good
yeah I'm excited I'm so glad I'm so
pleased it was really nerve-wracking to
not know anything about it right where
has been a long time I'm feeling very
good about all the hard work we put in
including Ben and dealing with his
Keepers sticking a needle in him every
day even though it's a small needle very
proud of him just let me know when he's
back to training and we can get his
insulins I started again okay cool all
right thanks Cindy these blood results
mean that we are able to control Ben's
diabetes really well and the most
important part of his control is the
keepers being able to give insulin
injections so without their training of
Ben to receive a daily insulin injection
he would definitely be much sicker and I
don't know if he'd be with us right now
foreign
[Music]
it's been a crazy week but I'm almost
done I'm on my way to stop off at the
koala building to see Ruan as my last
check
Korea to Taylor Australia I want to make
sure that her eye is healing well I
happen to miss the CT scan so I just
want to catch up and see how she's doing
I told her you're coming she was so
excited she stayed in the same spot
that looks so good that looks so good
good yeah I'm thrilled she's so good
after looking at the right eye it looks
remarkably better it's massively
improved it almost looks like it's
completely healed and resolved even the
blood vessels have regressed which means
they've done their job and they're like
bye-bye but there's a little scar but it
looks flat it's it looks fantastic
Ramon's gonna have a little bit of
scarring on the eye which is okay she
still seems to be able to see well so
that scarring shouldn't affect her at
all she's in great health overall for a
16 year old koala we're really hopeful
that she will spend a lot more years
with us she's a great part of the
program and she's just our resident old
lady bye Roo I see you in a few days see
you next week
foreign
[Music]